Grandpa where are we you need to
discover the world's Mysteries
magic is all around us there's no such
thing
gather round I bring you a creature only
whispered about in myth and Legend
it can't be
it is
no bottle has seen one for centuries
they might look cute
hi Gizmo I'm Sam but this species is
wildly dangerous
is that true
how dangerous can this be
nobody else has concerns
[Music]
you must return him to his home
I'm coming with you
wonderful we have a map that no one
understands except a magical squirrel
that speaks gibberish
I'm guessing this doesn't translate to
everything's fine
[Applause]
let's get these mogwives go get him Sam
you know Kung Fu
[Music]